hi I'm Tim van derham I'm the vice
president of development and engineering
for IBM bluemix my vm crew sure did 16
years ago in Rochester Minnesota as an
intern and now here I am at the center
of IBM's cloud strategy with IBM bluemix
disruption is real it is happening in
every industry and an every geography
around the world and developers are at
the center of this disruption the demand
from our clients to interact with us
differently is happening today
developers are those that enable it they
have the power they have the keys to the
kingdom that allow our companies to
truly transform how our clients interact
and do business with us data is the new
natural resource for our companies every
company has a growing wealth of data but
more than just taking that data in its
raw natural form we need to synthesize
it aggregate it refine it and make it
useful so developers are taking the
synthesized useful data combining it
through the development of their
applications with other AP is in the API
economy and the API ecosystem and
they're changing the user experience for
your consumers every company must rely
on this digital transformation because
our consumers are demanding a different
way to do business with us and interact
with us they are looking for a better
user experience the cloud is enabling a
rapid innovation platform that allows
developers to rapidly innovate change
applications to build better solutions
for your company IBM bluemix is the
digital innovation platform for
developers that allows them to unlock
their creative minds and all that
potential that they have to transform
the way your company does business